a quote that i heard a very early age by  buckminster fuller which is we have the  ability to house clothe feed and educate  everyone on the planet why don't we if  we don't start thinking about how we  arrest and work with those things that  hold us back as individuals and hold us  back as societies we won't move forward  we'll actually start devolving one way  for us to start enacting those systemic  changes that we need to see  is by giving people a vision of a future  that we want  this is what a functioning democracy  looks like this is what a functioning  education system a functioning criminal  justice this is what it could look like  as opposed to you know the wire or as  opposed to all these things that we see  it could actually look like this we're  in this pivotal moment what we do or  don't do over the next 10 to 15 years  will have a knock-on effect for hundreds  if not thousands of years